salve non vi parlerò di piante madri
farli rodi
e crollato e integro interno alle piante
e anche a noi
si parla di un tema che riguarda come il
mantenimento della biodiversità negli
alimenti nell'ambiente che ci circonda e
nelle piante sia fondamentale per
tenerci in salute
quindi per tenerci vivi biodiversità di
un tipo particolare di diversità
microbica quando voi sentite parlare dei
microrganismi nella parola stessa mero
organismo
c'è un tratto che sicuramente comuni al
pensiero di ogni persona in questa sala
non si vede è piccolo e quando una cosa
estremamente piccola la prima cosa che
dà l'impressione che ci dà è un senso di
paura perché qualcosa che non conosciamo
l'approccio che noi abbiamo avuto da
assimil organismi è stato mediato da
grandi tragedie poter ricordare
semplicemente la peste
voglio ricordare la spagnola e proprio
negli anni in cui cominciavamo a poterli
studiare perché attraverso i microscopi
e strumenti ci vedevamo gli abbiamo
associati a qualcosa di negativo c'è un
libro molto bello che si chiama mike
writers che è stato scritto nel 28 e che
spiega esattamente come dalla
descrizione dei costrutti di koch si sia
associato il mio organismi e malattie
negli ultimi dieci anni questa
prospettiva ha subito una rivoluzione
completa e un totale cambiamento di
prospettiva
negli ultimi dieci anni utilizzando le
stesse tecniche che abbiamo utilizzato
per sequenziare genomi umani abbiamo
cominciato a sequenziare in meta genomi
umani
cosa sono i metalli nomi è l'insieme di
quei microrganismi che non riusciamo a
coltivare ma identifichiamo unicamente
grazie a una firma basata su una
sequenza di dna questi microrganismi
qui c'è un indicazione sugli ordini di
questi microrganismi presenti sulla
pelle nell'intestino sul seno nelle
orecchie
questi microrganismi sono responsabili
non solo e anzi quasi mai delle nostre
malattia ma so responsabili del nostro
mantenimento il salute nell'equilibrio
fra noi che il nostro sistema immune
quindi qui voglio darvi una nuova
immagine di voi voi avete sempre pensato
di essere insieme di cellule delle
vostre cellule ma in realtà per ognuna
delle vostre cellule ci sono 10 batteri
e quando io comincio a chiedermi chi
sono profondamente capisco che mentre io
ho 10 x 10 alla dodicesima cellule i
miei batteri forniscono cento per 10
alla dodicesima cellule e su 80 kg
difese di una persona circa due chili
sono fatti proprio di questi batteri
quando andiamo agli elementi codificanti
che ci dicono chi siamo cioè i geni
avete sentito plevani parlarne oggi noi
abbiamo all'incirca il numero cambia
continuamente 30 mila geni i nostri
batteri c contribuiscono informazione
pari a un milione di funzioni cioè i
nostri microrganismi anno un milione di
geni senza di loro non vivremo quindi il
paradosso che io propongo è che noi
siamo o loge nomi che camminano questo è
l'uomo vitruviano e il centro si sposta
dal cervello al gac brain al cervello
che sostanzialmente nella nostra pancia
ci sono degli studi bellissimi che
stanno avvenendo avanti su questa linea
di ricerca c'è un'ipotesi che i batteri
decidano le nostre preferenze alimentari
batteri parli ai nostri sembra il valore
centrale e chi è un vegetariano o vegano
abbia un cross stop un dialogo fra batte
dell'intestino e testa diversa da un
carnivoro perché il carnivoro cerca una
preda l'italiano coltiva quindi sono due
approcci completamente diversi ha una
visione del mondo e questi due approcci
completamente diversi sono fondamentali
per moltissime delle nostre funzioni
come vi ho detto
circa due file di batteri
che parlano al nostro sistema immune
sulla superficie che è circa 300 metri
quadrati cioè ognuno di noi ha una
superficie di 300 metri quadrati i
nostri batteri ci parlano attraverso
questi 300 metri quadrati e fanno cose e
mi un training addestrano il nostro
sistema immunitario
dove li prendiamo sono un'altra di
quelle cose per cui le nostre madri sono
molto più importanti dei nostri padri
la prima contaminazione la prima
colonizzazione del bambino viene dalla
madre quindi la madre sostanzialmente il
seme che determina i batteri della
famiglia durante la nostra crescita
questi batteri praticamente vengono
cambiati dalla dieta e ci servono per
combattere i patogeni per capire come
questo metagenoma evolve noi siamo
andati a cercare le tracce di questa
evoluzione in africa perché siamo
partiti da una ipotesi
negli ultimi 20 mila anni da quando
sostanzialmente siamo passati al
neolitico la rivoluzione del neolitico e
quella in cui l'uomo ha iniziato a
coltivare noi siam passati da cacciatori
raccoglitori ha praticamente stanziali
durante la rivoluzione del neolitico la
coltivazione ha portato a dei grandi
vantaggi che quella di cominciare a
nutrirsi favorendo la produttività della
terra che ci circonda ha portato anche a
dei grandi svantaggi di randy pericoli
abbiamo cominciato a vivere in villaggi
in comunità questo è andato in parallelo
allo sviluppo delle prime malattie
evolutivamente è cruciale perché se un
cacciatore raccoglitore muore di
un'infezione muore e lui non muore tutta
la comunità
se una persona che vive una comunità si
infetta e rischia di morire di
un'infezione la può trasmettere agli
altri della comunità quindi diciamo
questo senso di controllo collettivo è
aumentato enormemente questi studi gli
studi su quelli che noi chiamiamo in
paesi in via di sviluppo
ci stanno dando informazioni
preziosissime preziosissime per noi una
persona che è fondamentale che si muova
da lì franco e primo notò
che in africa e nei paesi in via di
sviluppo
cancro al colon e malattie autoimmuni
erano praticamente a zero poi di rete va
beh come ci ha detto cingolani oggi
tanto muoiono prima di poter sviluppare
no se voi fate un match aging cioè
prendete persone del classic della
stessa classe di età quindi 15 anni ai
vent'anni in africa che il morbo di
crohn e zero negli ultimi 50 anni
da noi il morbo di crohn e sta
aumentando in modo esponenziale come
tutte le malattie autoimmuni questa
osservazione questo grafo e vedete sulla
destra si fa vedere sostanzialmente come
in verde in africa e nei paesi in cui
sostanzialmente si mangia in modo ancora
vicina la natura si è contaminata dai
batteri questi marchi autoimmuni sono a
zero questo studio ci ha portato a
chiederci ok a che livello la
globalizzazione della dieta cioè il
fatto che tutti noi consumi consumiamo
alimenti di origine industriale che per
legislazione europea sono privi dei
microrganismi usati per produrli cioè il
pane e voi mangiate non ha più lieviti
se lo comprate in panetteria il lardo di
colonnata le nostre alimenti
tradizionali per cui non chiedono
applauso perché non è esattamente la
cosa migliore potete mangiare ma non fa
male è prodotto in un modo per qui è
bandito dalla comunità europea secondo
le regole di sanitizzazione europee
domanda è com'è che mangiare una dieta
occidentale standardizzata sta cambiando
il nostro microbiota siamo andati a
chiedercelo in africa questo studio
avuto più di 600 citazioni e stato preso
dall economist e da diversi dati
quinteri visto l'argomento è il primo
studio che cercava di capire e la nostra
eredità ancestrale cioè quello che
stavamo perdendo passando da una dieta
tra virgolette vicina alla terra a una
dieta lontana dalla terra
se andate a studiare un villaggio in
burkina faso abul pon in cui
sostanzialmente le persone preparano il
cv in maniera collettiva quella che
vedete ii e una tavola
praticamente la tavola in cui le donne
del villaggio separano il cibo e il cibo
sostanzialmente viene coltivato in
quella zona è tutto a un ciclo chiuso
cioè siamo completamente a chilometri
zero perché di fatto carne prodotti
animali non se ne consumano quasi una
dieta quasi completamente vegetariane
abbiamo utilizzato un approccio
estremamente moderno per studiarlo
utilizzato strumenti che san michele
grazie all'intelligenza di chi ce li ha
messi a disposizione ha fornito
dall'istituto abbiamo fatto il
metabolomico è tutti i metaboliti
abbiamo studiato tutte le specie
batteriche presenti dei campioni e tutte
le funzioni di quelle specie batteriche
a livello di dna milioni e milioni di
sequenze la bioinformatica è servita per
interpretarle e per classificare
praticamente la diversità che trovavamo
in questi graffi
la torta di sopra di far vedere
praticamente la diversità dei bambini
del burkina la torta di sotto vi fa
vedere la diversità di bambini toscani
che mai non mangiano la cosa
interessante è che abbiamo scoperto che
i bambini il burkina apprendono dalle
termiti che mangiano la loro dieta
perché le assumono normalmente dalla
tavola ma l'immagine indipendentemente
due specie batteriche una si chiama
siliani butter che degradano le fibre
altissima efficienza queste specie
batteriche portano alla produzione di
molecole che si chiamano jorge infetti
exit acidi grassi a catena corta queste
molecole sono il toccasana
dell'intestino l'industria farmaceutica
occidentale sta provando di sviluppare
prodotti che le diano al nostro
intestino praticamente le facciano
arrivare nel colon per prevenire cose
per prevenire col cancro al colon per
prevenire crohn e polline colite
ulcerosa a sinistra quelle colonne vita
fanno vedere i livelli di jorge infatti
esse dei bambini africani cinque volte
superiori a quelle degli occidentali
non solo questi bambini bevono acqua di
pozzo contaminata io dal microbiologo di
formazione mi aspettavo di trovare i
pieni di patogeni il contrario
sulla sinistra e scarica coli salmonella
cgil clip sel specie di batteri patogeni
presenti nell'intestino i bambini
africani sulla destra
le stesse specie presenti nei bambini
europei perché queste specie proliferano
grazie alla presenza di zuccheri
semplici grazie alla presenza di
proteine nobili della carne praticamente
quindi una dieta che esclude
completamente le cosiddette profili nei
nobili e che elimina gli zuccheri
semplici automaticamente per
competizione favorisce la crescita di
microrganismi che degradano fibra e che
consentono di estrarre energia e
sostanze nutrienti l'oro del 2000 da
alimentazioni tradizionali su ball a
nere e dall'altro qui vengono le ultime
e secondo me cruciale domande che tutti
noi ci troviamo affrontare oggi cosa
possiamo fare per salvaguardare la
nostra microflora teoricamente non
possiamo cominciare a mangiare termiti
mangiando anche praticamente fibra
dobbiamo trovare un integrazione di
funzioni altro esperimento abbiamo fatto
abbiamo provato a dare solo le fibre
senza i batteri che beneficio non c'era
e la combinazione delle due che porta al
miglioramento
l'idea è che praticamente noi stiamo
perdendo funzioni a causa di una dieta
sempre più standardizzata ma che non
basta aumentare la complessità di questa
dieta bisogna aumentarne anche la
naturalezza cioè la complessità globale
tener conto e una dieta non è fatta
soltanto di proteine zuccheri aminoacidi
ma è fatta anche di quegli enzimi e
batteri che li trasformano e che li
rendono assorbibili dal nostro organismo
quindi la nostra microflora è in un
delicatissimo equilibrio dinamico
nasciamo la ereditiamo e l'abbiamo
ereditata da generazioni probabilmente
attraverso la nostra cultura
oggi ce la troviamo standardizzata
quando utilizziamo antibiotici o quando
abbiamo crisi di vario tipo anche uno
stress psicologico portare un
cambiamento grosso
il campo il passaggio e come quello da
un prato fiorente a quello che vedete
accanto sia un terreno spoglio se io o
il treno spoglio non lo coltivo e non ci
rimetto i microrganismi giusti che cosa
riescono rofi quindi noi dobbiamo
tendere a associare gli alimenti ai
microrganismi che questi alimenti hanno
fatto perché la fermentazione da secoli
è stata il nostro modo per selezionare i
microrganismi giusti per la nostra
salute
quindi nel recupero della tipicità degli
alimenti e del nucleo della complessità
bisogna recuperare questo equilibrio
questo stiamo facendo in trentino
abbiamo iniziato un progetto a san
michele all'adige in collaborazione con
altre strutture che il mio progetto che
che ha praticamente un facebook dei
microrganismi del trentine del nord
italia di sono toscano quindi sto
comparando le due popolazioni e stiamo
cercando ha capito niente di studiarli
in modo intelligente cioè usiamo
petabyte di memoria per in per comparare
praticamente l'informazione delle
sequenze di queste i batteri con quelli
presenti al mondo quindi poter dire cosa
è veramente tipici e come sassi trova
dappertutto e stiamo cercando di
associarlo a test che danno la risposta
del sistema immune a questi
microrganismi
cerchiamo di capire questi sono minor
crismi che non solo liberano sostanze
importanti ma danno la salute al sistema
immunitario di chi li assume
noi crediamo che questo approccio
integrato porti l'agricoltura sulla
tavola in modo intelligente e allontani
l'ospedale allontani il dottore cioè
aiuti a integrarlo e aiuti a curarsi
attraverso gli alimenti e attraverso i
microrganismi curarsi in modo
completamente naturale
noi pensiamo che questo sia veramente un
cambio di paradigma che deve entrare
nella nostra legislazione e deve essere
importato nelle legislazioni europee
dobbiamo ripensare quello che noi
definiamo un alimento sano grazie